أكد إيلون ماسك
أن تقارير CNN الحصرية بأن شركته SpaceX تخطط
لوقف أو تقليص تمويلها بشكل كبير
لخدمات الإنترنت عبر الأقمار الصناعية
في أوكرانيا
والتي كانت أساسية
في قتال الجيش الأوكراني ضد روسيا.
ما يقرب من 100 مليون دولار وعرض
أسعار لسنا في وضع يسمح
لنا بالتبرع بالمحطات الطرفية إلى أوكرانيا أو
تمويل المحطات الحالية
لفترة غير محددة من الوقت.
من المسك قال إننا نتبع
توصيته على الأقل
كيف يرى المسك أن يترك أوكرانيا هذا
الانفجار من الدبلوماسي الأوكراني الذي
جاء في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر بعد أن
اقترح المسك خطة سلام رأى العديد من
الأوكرانيين أنها مؤيدة
لروسيا تمنح روسيا سيطرة رسمية على شبه جزيرة القرم
وتشجيع انتخابات جديدة تحت إشراف الأمم
المتحدة تسمح بضم المناطق  في
أوكرانيا للانضمام إلى روسيا ، هذا يمثل
تحديًا لنا جميعًا
للإدارة لكل من يريد أن
يرى أوكرانيا تنجح في جعل إيلون ماسك
يتصرف بطريقة حقيقية في عطارد
يطرح مقترحات
لحل دبلوماسي لحرب وحشية حيث تكون
النتيجة الوحيدة المقبولة بصراحة  ينبغي أن
تستمر أوكرانيا في استعادة
أراضيها من الغزاة الروس ،
وقد نفى مسك الأمة الطيبة تقريرًا
قال فيه لخبير السياسة الخارجية إيان بريمر
أنه تحدث مباشرة إلى
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بشأن أوكرانيا ،
لكن المخاوف بشأن دعم المسك
لأوكرانيا نمت فقط عندما زاد بعض الأوكرانيين.
ذكرت القوات أنها لا تستطيع
الوصول إلى إنترنت ستارلينك أثناء تقدمهم
وحاولوا استعادة مناطق
من روسيا.
إضافة شئنا أم
أبينا ساعدنا Elon Musk على البقاء على قيد الحياة أكثر
لحظات الحرب الحرجة